who is god then
let's try to sneak up to this question
if it's at all possible is it possible
to even talk about this
well it better be because otherwise
there's no communicating about it right
it it has to be something that can be
brought down to earth
well we might be too dumb to bring it
down it's not just ignorant it's also
sinful
right
so because there's not knowing and then
there's not wanting to know or refusing
to know yeah and so you might say well
could you extract god from a description
of the objective world
right is is god just the ultimate unity
of
of of
of the natural reality and i would say
well
in a sense there's some truth in that
but but not exactly because
god in the highest sense is the spirit
that you must emulate in order to
thrive
how's that for a biological definition
spirit is a pattern
the spirit that you must emulate in
order to thrive so it's a kind of uh in
one sense
when we say the human spirit
it's that
it's an animating principle
yeah it's a meta it's a pattern
and you might say well what's the
pattern okay well i can tell you that to
some degree
imagine that
like your grip by beauty you're gripped
by admiration
so and you can just notice this this
isn't propositional you have to notice
it it's like oh
turns out i admire that person
so what does that mean well it means i
would like to be like him or her that's
what admiration means it means there's
something about the way they are that
compels
imitation
another instinct
or inspires respect or awe
even
okay what is that that grips you
well
i don't know well let's say okay fine
but it grips you and you want to be like
that kids hero worship for example so do
adults for that matter unless they
become entirely cynical i worship quite
a quite a few heroes yeah well there you
go proudly yes well there you go and
there's no that worship that celebration
and proclivity to imitate is worship
that's what worship means most
fundamentally now imagine you took
the set of all admirable people
and you extracted out ai learning you
extracted out the central features of
what constitutes admirable
and then you did that repeatedly until
you purified it to what was most
admirable
that's as good as you're going to get
in
in terms of a representation of god
and you might say well i don't believe
in that it's like
well
what do you mean yeah it's not a set of
propositional facts
it's not a scientific theory about the
structure of the objective world and
then i could say something about that
too because i've been thinking about
this a lot especially since talking to
richard dawkins
it's like okay
the post-modernist types
going back way before daradan foucault
maybe back to nietzsche
who i admire greatly by the way
he says god is dead
it's like okay
but nietzsche said god is dead and we
have killed him and will not find enough
water to wash away all the blood so that
was nietzsche he's no fool he's got away
with words he certainly does
and so then you think okay well we
killed the transcendent
well
what does that mean for science well it
frees it up because all that nonsense
about a deity is just the idiot
superstition that stops the scientific
um
what process from moving forward that's
basically the new atheist claim
something like that it's like wait a
second
do you believe in the transcendent if
you're a scientist
and the answer is
well not only do you believe in it you
believe in it more than anything else
because if you're a scientist
you believe in
what objects to your theory
more than you believe in your theory now
we've got to think that through very
carefully so your theory describes the
world and as far as you're concerned
your description of the world is the
world
but because you're a scientist you think
well even though that's my description
of the world and that's what i believe
there's something beyond what i believe
and that's the object and so i'm going
to throw my theory against the object
and see where it'll break and then i'm
going to use the evidence of the break
as a source of new information to
revitalize my theory so as a scientist
you have to posit the existence of the
ontological transcendent before you can
move forward at all
but more
you have to posit that contact with the
ontological transcendent
annoying though it is because it upsets
your apple cart is exactly what will in
fact set you free
so then you accept the proposition that
there is a transcendent reality
and that the that contact with that
transcendent reality is redemptive in
the most fundamental sense because if it
wasn't why would you bother making
contact with you're going to make
everything worse or better
why does the
contact with the transcendent
set you free as a scientist because you
assume that you assume i mean freedom in
the most fundamental sense it's like
well freedom from want freedom from
disease freedom from ignorance right
that it informs you so the logos in it
of science
it is definitely that
yeah it's it's the wa it's the direction
let's say the directionality of science
that's a narrative direction not a
scientific direction and then the
question is what is the narrative well
it posits a transcendent reality it
posits that the transcendent reality is
corrective it posits that our knowledge
structure should be regarded with
humility it posits that you should bow
down in the face of
of the transcendent evidence and you
have to take a vow you know this as a
scientist you have to take a vow to
follow that path if you're going to be a
real scientist it's like the truth
no matter what and that means you posit
the truth as a redemptive force
well what does redemptive mean well why
bother with science well so people don't
starve so people can move about more
effectively so life can be more abundant
right so it's all ensconced within an
underlying ethic so the the reason i i
was saying that while we were talking
about belief in god it's like this is a
very complicated topic right do you
believe in a transcendent reality see
okay now let's say
you buy the argument i just made on the
natural front you say yeah yeah that's
just nature
that's not god
and then i'd say well what makes you
think you know what nature
is like see the problem with that
argument is that it it already presumes
a materialist a reductionist materialist
objective view of what constitutes
nature but if you're a scientist you're
going to think
well in the final analysis i don't know
what nature is i certainly don't know
its origin or destination point i don't
know it's teleology i'm really ignorant
about nature
and so when i say it's nothing but
nature
i shouldn't mean it's nothing but what i
understand nature to be
so i could say will we have a fully
reductionist account of cognitive
processes
and the answer to that is yes but by the
time we do that our understanding of
matter will have transformed so much
that what we think of as reductionists
now won't look anything like this what
we think of reductionism now
matter isn't dead
dust
i don't know what it is
i have no idea what it is matter is what
matters there's a definition that's a
very weird definition but
the notion that we have
you know that if you're a reductionist a
materialist reductionist that you can
reduce
the complexity of what is to your
assumptions about the nature of matter
that's not a scientific your specific
limited human assumptions of this
century of this week
that
so in that in some sense
without god in this complicated big
definition we're talking about
the there's no humility or
it's not enough there's less likely to
be
or rather science can err in
taking a trajectory away from humility
well without something much more
powerful
than an individual human yeah well then
and we know you know the frankenstein
story comes out of that instantly and
that's a good story for the current
times it's like
you you're playing around with making
new life
you bloody well better make sure you
have your arrows pointed up
and it's interesting because you said
science has
um an ethic to it
i think it's embedded in an ethic well
there's a
you know
science is a big word yeah and it
includes a lot of disciplines that have
different traditions so biology
chemistry
genetics physics
those are very different communities
and i think biology especially when you
get closer and closer to medicine into
the human body
does have a very serious first of all
has a history with nazi germany of being
abused and all those kinds of things
but it has a history of taking this
stuff seriously what doesn't have a
history of taking this stuff seriously
is robotics and artificial intelligence
which is really interesting
because
you don't uh you know you called me a
scientist but
and i i would like to wear that label
proudly but
often people don't think of computer
science as a science but nevertheless it
will be i think the science of one of
the major scientific fields of the 21st
century and you should take that very
seriously
oftentimes when people build robots
or ai systems they think of them
as uh like toys to tinker with oh isn't
this cool
well i feel this too isn't this cool it
is cool
but
you know uh at a certain moment you
might isn't this nuclear
uh explosion cool
yes it is or birth control pill cool
it's like or or transistor cool yeah
well the other thing too and and this is
a weird
problem in some sense the robotics
engineer types they're thing people
right i mean the big classes of interest
are interesting things versus interest
in people some of my best friends are
thing people yeah right and thing people
are very very
clear logical thinkers and they're very
outcome oriented and practical
now and that's all good
that makes the machinery and keeps it
functioning
but
there's a human side of the equation and
and you get the extreme thing people and
you think yeah well what about the human
here and
when we're talking about we've been
talking about the necessity of having a
technological enterprise embedded in an
ethic and you can ignore that like most
of the time right you can ignore the
overall ethic in some sense when you're
toying around with your toys but when
you're building an artificial
intelligence it's like well
that's not a toy
that might be
toy becomes the monster very cool yeah
yeah yes yes and and this is a whole new
kind of monster
and maybe it's already here
yes and you notice how many of those
things you can no longer turn off
and what is it with you engineers and
your inability to put off switches on
things now
it's like i have to hold this for five
seconds for it to shut off or i can't
figure i just want to shut it off click
off well what is it with you humans that
don't uh put all switches on other
humans
because there's a magic to the thing
that you notice and it hurts
for both you and perhaps one day the
thing itself to turn it off
and so you have to be very careful as an
engineer adding off switches to things
i think it's a feature not a bug the off
switch
the off switch gives a deadline to us
humans to systems
of existence it makes you uh it's you
know death
is the thing that really brings clarity
to life and i do think hence the flaming
swords the flaming sword i do like your
view of the flame with the bush
and perhaps the sword
as a thing of transformation it's also
it's a transformation that kind of
consumes the thing in the process well
it depends on how much of the thing is
chaff
you know this is why you can't touch the
ark of the covenant
for example and this is why people can
have very bad psychedelic trips
it's like if you're 95 dead wood
and you get too close to the flame
the five percent that's left might not
be able to make it
so you think it's all chap but i think
there is some aspect of destruction that
is
that's you know the the bukowski line of
uh do what you love and let it kill you
right don't you think it that
destruction is part of that's humility
that's humility you bet you bet you bet
it's like
invite in the judgment invite in the
judgment because maybe you can die a
little bit instead of dying completely
yeah you know and that's i think it's
alfred north whitehead
we can let our ideas die instead of us
right we can have these partial
personalities that we can burn off
and we can let them go before they
become tyrannical pharaohs and
everything and we lose everything
and so yeah there's this optimal bite of
death and who knows
what it would mean to optimize that like
what if it was possible that if you died
enough all the time that you could
continue to live
and the thing is we already know that
biologically because
if you don't die properly all the time
well it's cancerous outgrowths and and
like it's a very fine balance between
productivity on the biological front and
the culling of that right
life is a real balance between growth
and death
and so what would happen if you got that
balance right well we kind of know right
because
if you live your life properly
so to speak and you're humble enough to
let your stupidity die before it takes
you out
you will live longer that's just a fact
well but then what's the ultimate
extension of that and the answer is we
don't know we have no idea
you